it's time for us to talk about two basic
types of neurotransmission excitation
and inhibition excitation and inhibition
require a delicate balance between pre
and postsynaptic processes signal
transmission is mediated by
neurotransmitters that are released
presynaptic Li and by a large complexity
of postsynaptic mechanisms and signaling
pathways the processes of excitation and
inhibition occur because this wild
assortment of mechanisms mediate
postsynaptic potentials presynaptic Li
the cast of characters is quite simple
we'll see for example that fast
excitatory postsynaptic potentials are
mediated primarily by cat ion selective
ion channels in the postsynaptic neuron
this happens alongside a host of other
complex and diverse postsynaptic players
involved in signaling pathways
comparatively the presynaptic terminal
is less of a party back in the post
synaptic terminal fast inhibitory
postsynaptic potentials are mediated
primarily by an ion selective ion
channels however are simple quiet little
neurotransmitters waiting in the
presynaptic terminal for their action
potential are absolutely necessary to
trigger postsynaptic mechanisms what's
so remarkable about them is the fact
that the delicate excitation inhibition
balanced throughout the brain can be
achieved with just a handful of
different types of neurotransmitters and
ions
[Music]
for example metabotropic receptors like
GPCRs will sense the neurotransmitter
and activate specific signal
transduction pathways that ultimately
change ion permeability and other
processes inside the cell other
postsynaptic players like ampa and nmda
receptors which mediate excitatory
communication and synaptic plasticity in
the central nervous system are permeable
to many different types of ions the
party is clearly happening
postsynaptically
[Music]
you
[Music]
you